dans ce restaurant de la banlieue de
Moscou depuis l'intervention en Ukraine
du 24 février les affaires marchent
plutôt bien
le McDonald's voisin a fermé ses portes
mais ce n'est pas la seule raison selon
le gérant
le chiffre d'affaires a augmenté de 10%,
je crois que c'est parce que les gens ne
parlent plus à l'étranger et dépensent
davantage en Russie
pizza et pâtes sont fabriquées avec des
ingrédients 100% italiens mais avec les
sanctions internationales il a fallu
s'adapter
aujourd'hui nous travaillons avec cinq
fournisseurs contre deux auparavant
parce que certains ont augmenté les prix
de la farine d'autres le prix du fromage
pour ce qui est de la farine on a deux
mois de réserves mais on se prépare dès
aujourd'hui à utiliser de la farine
russe
si la forme paye il ouvrira un deuxième
restaurant d'ici 2 ans
même pragmatisme dans cette manufacture
de montre la plus vieille de Russie
la marque rachetée par un Français en
2011 a dû reporter le lancement de
certains modèles comme celui fabriqué à
partir de ce morceau de métal
c'est une aile d'un avion de chasse
migrant
voilà donc en raison du contexte on
reporte un peu la sortie des montres qui
sont sur une thématique militaire
pour des raisons évidentes et on se
concentre plus sur des montres qui
parlent de l'art démontre plus classique
ou qui parle de l'espace la montre des
héros soviétiques a aussi dû changer de
fournisseur certains éléments qui
provenaient d'Europe comme les bracelets
ou l'huile des machines sont désormais
confectionnés en Russie mais d'autres
composants y sont introuvables c'est le
cas du saphir poli le verre qui referme
le cadran de la montre
et c'est des aires de fond avec des
faces des angles les angles des ondes
précis et ça donc c'est très difficile à
trouver des fournisseurs on a fait le
pivot le fameux pivot vers l'Asie c'est
effectué donc on n'a pas attendu ne plus
avoir de stock pour ce pour commencer à
s'écarter si vendre en Occident est
devenu plus compliqué la marque peut
compter sur un regain de patriotisme ça
fait ça fait 10 ans qu'on se bat pour
essayer d'expliquer aux Russes que il
n'y a pas que les montres suisses qui
existent au monde les montres russes
sont aussi qualitatives à la rencontre
de belles histoires et là durant les
deux derniers mois ce message passe
beaucoup mieux outre le marché national
le fabricant vise désormais la Chine
l'Inde ou le Moyen-Orient de quoi
espère-t-il maintenir son chiffre
d'affaires autour de 5 millions et demi
d'euros